hey whats up guys Mary here showing off
gamespot's the mix at e3 2015 i'm here
with bilal you're a developer with
brain-seed factory right and we are
going to be showing off type oh man this
is on the wii u exactly awesome well
let's take a look at it right now and
get into it so tell me a little bit
about what type o man is type of man is
a puzzle platformer it has a very unique
game world you play a little character
which is made of ink he's literally made
of letters um and your goal is to solve
puzzles here but not with traditional
means like weapons or something over
enemies or something like that you craft
words to overcome traps and monsters it
looks like you came out of words right
then when you fell as well so there's
actual letters littered throughout this
world right exactly letters letters are
not only visual tools or graphical
flourishes they are also gameplay
elements so you interact with letters
you call them you push them and you use
them to create to craft new words in
this case you have to push that letter
letter to the letter so you can climb up
otherwise you can't reach it and the
challenge is to examine the environment
and think about what you have to do to
solve the puzzle now I can't help but
notice that the environment is a little
ominous and a little dark there's a
there's some sad elements going on back
there what kind of environment did you
want the player to be in when you made
this game yeah so the game has a very
large story and we want the player to
figure out the story on the fly while
it's playing and there are different
hints that will have him figure it out
himself so in addition to the puzzle
element is there some platforming as
well some quick quick there's gonna be
times you're gonna need to be able to
you know think quick and jump in things
like that to be able to get through
areas exactly okay and you will have to
to die at certain times to figure out
how to solve it so it's also a trial by
deaf game yeah I get a big limbo vibe
from this game it looks like there's
elements of the fact that you're not
going to survive on your first run
you're going to have to do some trial
and error and that includes dying but
that's just a part of life exactly oh
that's awesome and as I've seen here
something was blocking you away you had
to examine the environment and come up
with a word with the letters that were
lying around and obviously it's down to
lower the gate that that was blocking
away so this was a pretty easy puzzle to
solve the next one will be a bit
trickier you have to think about the
situation you're in and how to solve it
and there are different mechanics that
you can use for example swinging on
ropes to overcome pits yeah yeah it
looks like well if you were to fall
there that would probably be the end of
you would it not make sense but it's
really cute that you're using the words
grab to kind of hint towards the player
of what they're supposed to be doing
except there's also times when these
letters won't be helping you and you
need to figure out how to actually use
them yeah you're seeing the words use
and part and parts moving parts moving
and becoming a trap what's around it its
own axis that's um but like I said there
are different hints that that will lead
you to the solution here for somebody
you take a look at this sign in with CBS
moving alright and sold off it falls off
and then you have to think about what to
do with the S that's at your disposal
and you combine the words the letter
without having them smash down by the
track I see then you can then you can
change the word the meaning of the word
to have it become something something
else
well interesting so if you got it to be
in the front would it would be strauch
exactly it would be like the end goal
here my deductive logic i think that's
Harley what we're going to be doing here
with its rich it's off its tricky ass um
you have to place it in the right spot
to have it become another word strap
awesome this is fantastic is the meaning
of the word and this is how you solve
puzzles here base all right thank you
miss me so this is coming out on Wii U
right exactly all right there's any
other platforms in mind or weave right
now no no it's cvu explicit were you
exclusive and this is from head up games
as publishing this yeah oh and you say
later this year is when you're kind of
looking for q3 he's somewhere around so
how far in uh into the development cycle
would you say you are at a completed
most um the game development is nearing
ya know ya words can turn into a hostile
enemies fun to rip your head off in this
case this hate monster what you have to
do is lure him to the crashplan oh no
she didn't get crushed so he can get
crushed oh gosh exactly and now this
story is pretty ambiguous at this stage
but it looks like throughout this world
you'll be getting more clues into what
you're doing in this world may be who
you are and maybe a larger purpose and
it is right now it's pretty vague we're
not really sure exactly what we're doing
we just keep going forward yeah um if
you look closely at the character you
can see that he's made of letters on the
letters form of words themselves so the
legs are the age the upper body is the e
the arm is the arm and the head is be oh
so you have it so you are the hero and
you um you are on a quest and like I
said there are many hints that will and
that will reveal the the quest that
you're on
and and the story has has various layers
the first and obvious layer is that you
are the hero and have to overcome traps
and monsters and fight through this
surreal hostile world you're trapped in
yeah it looks like everything's trying
to kill the hero right now yeah but
later on you will see what your request
is which is that you have to find your
other arm because you have only one arm
well that's right I'd even noticed that
at first so the meaning of himself will
also change into something else once you
find your second arm that's right well
it probably is a letter that adds to
hero maybe oh baby oh baby changing I
don't want this fun too much yeah well
it's pretty cool I love the idea of
looking at the words and just
effectively changing them up and mixing
it up a little bit too to add to the
puzzle of this gameplay it's a really
unique element I've never seen anything
like this before me neither that's
probably why you wanted to make exactly
yes we took a lot of time to come up
with all these puzzles that make sense
in that yeah but suck you in into this
in this game also what we have here you
have the end of the demo where um you
meet this this this character here which
is something like your guardian angel
and this is the missing body part that
you're searching on the quest to find it
it looks like an eighth note that's
something else yeah
your arm is the R and the second arm the
P but and a giant evil monster Oh No
don't let you have it well it looks
really stunning I think who's obviously
a lot to uncover and I feel like we're
just barely scratching the surface of
what this game has to offer so that was
typo ma'am thank you so much for showing
me that well thank you for having me
here all right awesome so there's going
to be a lot more comin be sure to stay
tuned to gamespot for all that III
coverage thanks a lot guys